مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه
الجديده ل التحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب
اسرائيل على غزه نرحب بضيف هذه النافذه
اللواء فايز دويري مرحبا بك دكتور حياك
الله وارحب بزميلي عبد القادر والذي نبدا
معه في قراءه للخريطه التفاعليه وما يجري
في البدايه من خانون الساع القادر نعم
فعلا محمد لعل التطورات اللافته بالخصوص
في الجبهه الجنوبيه تستدعي ان نركز عليها
بدايه في هذا العرض وحينما نشير الى خان
يونس في الجنوب لابد ان نذكر بان
ابرز الاستهدافات وعمليات القصف وان كانت
في المناطق المختلفه لكنها تركزت بالاساس
في المنطقه الوسطى وتحديدا في مخيمات
البريج وايضا النصيرات ولكن ايضا في خان
يونس وسنشير الى تفاصيلها من خلال عمليه
استهداف ذهب ضحيتها عدد كبير من الشهداء
لو ذهبنا اذا الى المنطقه الجنوبيه
وتحديدا خان يونس ربما سنشير الى مجموعه
من المعطيات الجيش الاسرائيلي تحدث على
انه يتقدم باتجاهات مختلفه وقال بانه يركز
يركز عمليته في الجنوب وتحديدا في خان
يونس في محاوله لتحقيق جمله اهداف كنا
اشرنا الى عمليه توغل للجيش الاسرائيلي
واشرنا الى صور الاقمار الصناعيه التي
حصلت عليها الجزيره والتي اشارت الى ان
وجود نحو 300 300 اليه عسكريه في تحديدا
في خان يونس راوح مكانها لكن اللافت هو
عمليه القصف المكثف التي طالت العديد من
المواقع وسنركز على هته المواقع تحديدا
امام مستشفى الامل التابع لجمعيه الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني ولكن ايضا اعلان وزاره
الصحه عن مخاوفها من عمليات القصف التي
تطال مناطق قريبه من مستشفى الناصر لو
ذهبنا الى الخريطه التفصيليه
والمقرب نحن كما نشاهد مستشفى الامل يقع
في منطقه سكانيه كثيفه كثافه كثافه سكانيه
كبيره فيها وايضا مستشفى نصر نحن نتحدث عن
عمق هذه المناطق عمليه الاستهداف لمبان في
هذه المواقع تاتي ايضا بينما كانت صور
الاقمار الصناعيه اظهرت عمليات تجريف ربما
قريبه نوعا ما من هذه الاماكن عمليه تجريف
في شمال غرب بني سهيله ولكن ايضا كانت
هناك عمليات تجريف ايضا في المناطق
القريبه من وسط مدينه خان يونس المقاومه
كتائب القسام بالمقابل كانت قد اعلنت هي
وايضا سرايا القدس عن استهداف اليات
عسكريه هنا في محاور عده في خانيونس رغم
هذا القصف الا ان المقاومه لازالت تبادر
لازالت تستهدف مختلف الاليات بل ان ايضا
سرايا القدس تحدثت عن
استهداف مجموع مجموعه راجله من الجنود
الاسرائيليين في محور
الكتيبه وقالت بانها اردت عددا منهم بين
قتيل وجريح لو ذهبنا الى المنطقه الوسطى
وتحديدا المنطقه الوسطى نحن نتحدث عن
تحديدا المنطقه الوسطى عفوا
اي المنطقه الوسطى في هذه المنطقه ربما
نشير الى تطوراتها بشكل بشكل كثيف بشكل
عفوا بشكل اكثر
تحديدا ربما هذه المناطق هي المناطق التي
تحدثنا عنها فيما يخص خان يونس المنطقه
الشماليه عفوا والتي شهدت ايضا مجموعه من
الاشتباكات بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
والقوات الاسرائيليه لكن ايضا كان هناك
ايضا قصف مكثف لعدد من المواقع تحديدا في
المناطق الشماليه لمدينه غزه
والمناطق الشرقيه سرايا القدس وكتائب
القسام تحدثت عن اشتباكات منذ الصباح في
عدد من محاور التقدم الاسرائيلي في هذه
المواقع اذا المنطقه الشماليه لازالت ايضا
بدورها تعيش على وقع هذه الاشتباكات بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات والقوات
الاسرائيليه لو ذهبنا الى المنطقه نوعا ما
المنطقه الوسطى وهي المنطقه التي شهدت
ايضا تطورات لافته لاحظوا معي مخيم البريج
ومخيم الصيرات من مخيمات في المنطقه
الوسطى التي تعرضت الى عمليات قصف مكثفه
نشير الى ان البريج شهد عمليات اعلنت عنها
كتائب القسام البارحه باستهداف اليات
عسكريه باستهداف ايضا دبابات ميركافا في
هذا الموقع ايضا سرايا القدس تحدثت ايضا
عن استهداف لهذه الاليات لكن اللافت ايضا
هو ان عمليات القصف طالت ايضا مخيم
النصيرات وقعت فيه مجزره فعمل استهداف
ايضا المنطقه الوسطى في ظل هذه التطورات
تاتي بين بينما كان الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن
بان الوحده رقم 36 بدات هجوما على هذه
المناطق الوسطى دون ان ننسى ايضا تطورات
على مستوى جحر الديك اذا تطورات على اكثر
من صعيد لعل ابرزها في خان يونس وعمليه
القصف اضافه الى المنطقه الوسطى وذاكر عبد
القادر سنبقى معك وسنبقى مع هذه الخريطه
نستغل التركيز الان الذي ختم منه عبد
القادر الواء فايز من المنطقه الوسطى ما
الذي تتوقعه لسيناريو القوات والتحركات
نتحدث عن مخيم
البريج منذ اكثر من 48 ساعه بدا التركيز
في بدء المعركه البريه في المنطقه الوسطى
و كوجهه نظر تحليليه نعم
اقول الان الخارطه لو نعم معنا مع الخارطه
تفضل الان اذا نظرنا الى الخارطه نحن
نتحدث عن ثلاث مخيمات ام البريج ان صارات
والمغازي لكن الان التكيز في البريج لا
ننظر الى منطقه البريج ان صيارات يوجد يمر
الفاصل بينهم شارع صلاح الدين نعم صباح
الامس دفع بالقوات وحاول ان يستثمر وجود
هذه الطريق استطاعت قوات المقاومه ان توقف
ذلك التقدم وتوقع خسائر وننتظر بيانات
المؤكده
الان اعاد النظر فيها و حاول ان يبحث عن
مقاربه اخرى لننظر الى خريطه البريج محاط
من ثلاث اتجاهات في مناطق يعتقد الجيش
الاحتلال انها مناطق رخوه لانها مناطق
مفتوحه وكما يقال تان كبل اريا تتحرك فيها
القوات ولكن لا اعتقد انها ستكون
اي قطعه سهله للسيطره عليها فدفع بالفرقه
36 من صباح الامس وليست وحده هي فرقه 36
ودفع بها لهذه المنطقه لكن السؤال
لماذا علينا ان نربط خارطه العمليات ام لو
نذهب ترفع الخارطه قليلا لو سمحت لي نذهب
الى المنطقه الوسطى اربط هذه المعركه معها
تريد ان ان تعود الى خانيونس بدي اعود الى
خان يونس اربط اربط هذه المعركه مع خان
يونس الى الخريطه الى الجم الجنوبيه لنظر
الى منطقه خان يونس كذلك الى شارع صلاح
الدين وهو الذي يقسم بن سهيله بصوره عامه
عن مدينه خان يونس
نعم العمليه لها اسابيع بدات في هذه
المنطقه وبدات من كوس فيم ووصل الى اطراف
مدينه الحمد والى منطقه المواصي والى اي
منطقه المستعمرات جوش قطيف الى غير ذلك ام
ولكنه واجه مقاومه شرسه وقلنا ان هذه
القوه توجد فيها هذه المنطقه توجد فيها
قوات متميزه لا يعني ان بقيه القوات غير
متميزه لا لكن هنا يوجد لواء خان يونس
ويوجد الوحدات الرئيسيه ووحدات النخبه
لبقيه الفصائل
ال سراي القدس و وبقيه الفصائل وبالتالي
خلال هذه الفتره من الاسابيع لا يزال
القتال والصور الجويه وضحناها وتحدثنا
عنها بالامس لا يزال عالقا في هذه المنطقه
الان هذا يقودني لماذا ذهب باتجاه البريج
نعم عله يحق دفع بالفرقه 36 عله يحقق
انجازات في منطقه البريج لانه نحن نتحدث
عن مسافات قريبه هذه الواجهه في الحروب
التقليديه واجهه غزه قد تكون اقل من واجهه
فرقه اذا عدنا الى الحرب العالميه الثانيه
لكن هو دفع ب 16 لواء اذا هو يحاول ان
يحقق انجازات في منطقه البريج على الاقل
على الاقل حتى لو لم يحقق انجازا هو يعتقد
ان القسام وبق بقيه الفصائل قد يلفت
انتباههم الى اتجاه اخر من المعركه يؤدي
الى اعاده التموضع واعاده النظر في اداره
المعركه مما يسهل عليه معركه بني سيلا
وتطويق خان يونس هل هنالك ربط بين ما يجري
في البريش وما يتم الاعلان عنه عن منطقه
عازله ليست شرقيه وانما داخل القطاع تفصل
الشمال عن الجنوب اشرت في اليوم الاول
عندما تم الحديث عن المنطقه العازله وقلت
المنطقه العازله حسب قراءتي للمعركه ل
العقليه والعقيده القتاليه الاسرائيليه
المنطقه ال العازله ستكون على طول الحدود
الز المنطقه الزراعيه في الحدود الشماليه
والشرقيه واذا استطاع الجنوبيه
وسيعمل طريقا عازلا بعمق ما بعرض 1 كيلو 2
كيلو في منطقه وادي غزه فصل الشمال عن
الاوسط والجنوب وهذا ما تسرب الحديث هذا
اليوم تحدثنا عنه قبل اكثر من خمسه ايام
كقراء استشراف وبالتالي هو سيسعى لتحقيق
ذلك لكن السؤال جحر
الديك متى دخلها اليوم الاول دخلها قبل
تقريبا
60 59 يوم ولغايه الان هي تعتبر احد اركان
المقاومه الرئيسيه فحتى لو تحدث عن سانشا
وانشئ وانشئ لن لا اعتقد ان لديه القدره
على التثبت بالامس تحدثنا عندما سئلت ما
هي القراءه لمدى المعركه وقلت من اثنين
الى ثلاثه اسبوع الان هو تحدث بنفس
الكلمات لكن بالنسبه لي كمحلل المدخلات
والمخرجات مختلفه عن المدخلات والمخرجات
لماذا لان شده المقاومه هي التي تمنع
وستحول على ذكر شده المقا قام هنالك
اشتباكات ما زالت حتى اليوم في المنطقه
الشماليه وفي اقصى الشمال الجيش يعلن عن
ثلاثه قتلى من الجنود من لواء جفعاتي
بينهم نائب قائد سريه في الشمال نعم لواء
لواء جفعاتي
ام هذا شكل قبل 48 وخضع لتغيرات كثيره وضع
على الاحتياط ثم ثم اعادته
الى الى تفعيله كقوه رئيسيه سجله
وقذر بالكابه المجازر وهو
الذي
ابتدع كسر الايدي في الانتفاضه الاولى الم
تكسر ايدي رمات الحجاره في الانتفاضه
الاولى كانوا جنود جفعاتي هم من ارتكبوا
هذه الجريمه ايام اسحاق رابين
وبالتالي تاريخه سيء تشكيله ثلاث كتائب
مشاه كتيبه وكتيبه احتياطيه تصبح اربعه
وكتيبه وكتيبه قوات خاصه تتالف من سريه
مقاومه دروع سريه هندسه سريه اسناد وسريه
كوماند الصحراوي وبالتالي يعتبر من من
الويه النخبه ذات التاريخ القذر والسجل
الحافل في الاجرام على ذكر الاجرام هنالك
حديث متواصل عن استمرار قصف المدنيين الان
الصحف الامريكيه تتحدث عن استخدام اسرائيل
حتى اللحظه القنابل او ئف التي تسميها غير
دقيقه رغم المطالبات الامريكيه بالحد من
الكلفه البشريه في الاستهداف ما تفسيرك
لاستمرار اسرائيل يعني اليوم مثلا شهوه
القتل مستشفى الامل شهوه القتل والرغبه في
القتل هذا الكيان وجيشه تم اذلاله للمره
الاولى في 7 اكتوبر فهو يحاول ان يرمم تلك
الصوره التي كانت سائده في الذهنيه
العربيه بانه الجيش الذي لا يقهر قهر واذل
كرامته فهو من منظور الانت قام وحب سفك
الدماء وبالتالي اين الاهداف العسكريه
التي حققها خلال 82 يوم من من بدء الحمله
حتى هذا اليوم لا يوجد انجاز عسكري فقط هو
ابدع في ممارسه القتل وارتكاب الجرائم
تهجير جماعي اباده جماعيه عمليات لا
انسانيه عمليات التعامل مع الاسرى جر جرف
المقابر لم يبقي نقطه في السجل اللا
اخلاقي الا مارس وبالتالي هذا امر لا
استغربه لانه اصلا تربيته تربيته وليعد
الى كما يقال الى اشعيه الم يتحدث نتنياهو
في محاضره له بالجنود عن مقتطفات من سفر
اشعيه التي تقول بقتل الرجال والنساء وبقر
بطون الحوامل وقتل الاطفال وقطع الشجر
وقتل الحيوان هذه ثقافتهم وهذه تربيتهم
اذا لا استغربوا ذلك سؤال اخير فيما يتعلق
بقطع الغيار لماذا تطلب اسرائيل وكيف
ستوفر ايضا
حديث وزاره الدفاع عن قطع غيار المركبه
ومركبات النمر قبل ان نتحدث لماذا الغت
صفقه الدبابات ميركافا اربعه الى قبرص
والى المغرب كانت اتفاقيات موقعه بسبب
الحاجه والاستهلاك العالي والتدمير الكبير
وبالتالي قبل ان يطلبوا هذه القطع طلبوا
اعاده البطاريه القبه الحديديه مع ذخيرتها
والتي سبق واشترتها امريكا ماذا ستفعل
سريعا في قطاع غيار اذا اذا هيانه بحكم
الحاجه لانه حتى المصانع الان الاحتياط
اين يعمل يعمل في القا القطاع الصناعي
والقطاع الزراعي وبالتالي يعني انخفضت
قدره الانتاج وبدا الان يحتاج واقولها
لولا المسانده الامريكيه لم لا يمكن لهذا
الجيش الفاشل ان يقاتل اكثر من اسبوعين
ولكن الذي ثبته الدعم الغربي شكرا شكرا
جزي لك اللواء فايز دوير الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي